it is finale time
itself patel how's it going you are
first
it is finale time walker bates hey
marvel studios i do do
i think until you pronounce that hello
gmc hello
max conrad what's up always here thank
you yo what up forsaken
we have two mods in the chat tonight
that's unheard of
what is up everybody all right
let's check the audio
can you guys hear me i don't think you
can hear me
oh it's playing oh i have it attached to
a speaker okay you guys can't hear me
iphone okay there it is whoo
malek shepard what's up what's up what's
up what's up dude
woof to everybody saying it how's it
going
all right this oh let me turn that down
but it looks like everything's good
with the live stream right
i believe so
we've got a while so
i just thought we could hang out in the
meantime
talk about all of our theories about
everything that uh
everything that we're thinking
all right
it's it's uh it's almost midnight it is
20 minutes till midnight for me
which means we have about an hour and 20
minutes unless they decide to open it up
early which you know
they have so
thank you max conrad for letting me know
that
uh it comes out in about an hour and 20
minutes move this water all the way
about an hour and 20 minutes so i've
come here to talk
what are we gonna see tonight um
i i just tweeted this out and i just put
this on instagram and i really really
really want the post credit scene
to be um
zmo at the raft and the thunderbolt ross
comes
and it like initiates him into the uh
into the thunderbolts that's what i
that's what i really want uh eastern
time no let's
i'm on uh mountain standard time
and it's gonna come out at
12 a.m pacific time that's it
5 40 p.m in new zealand dang
dang dang dang 340 in australia
oh i didn't know it was that big of a
difference between australia and new
zealand
interesting so predictions for any
final final thoughts about the falcon
winter soldier is sharon carter the
power broker
i hope so because and i don't hope that
in like a way
um that like she's bad or anything like
that i don't want her to be bad
but since she had to kind of fend for
herself after civil war
and new rockstars made a very good
argument that she was actually blipped
um so they didn't really reveal that
right like they didn't really reveal she
was blipped or not
um so that's kind of confusing because
the way she made it
seem is like she's been on the run
for like years and years and years and
years and years and years and years like
that's how oops
that's how she made it sound so i'm kind
of curious
i'm kind of curious like
what's her deal right we're gonna find
it out because we've seen like
the trailers of her and stuff like that
um
i'm seeing some people talk about uh i'm
seeing some people talk about chris
evans that's a hard one um
to know if he's gonna
if he's gonna show up or not because i
think if he does
somebody let me give him credit let me
look at my uh
let me look at my twitter to make sure
proper credit is given
oh it's lord it's a long box where's the
long box they
he said tempo flashback where old man
steve rogers is on his death bed talking
to sam something like that
i think it's going to be some type of
flashback i i
i think if we steve see steve rogers
it's going to be like that i don't think
we're going to get like a funeral for
him
uh i don't think i don't think anything
like that
uh i really don't i think it's gonna be
some type of flashback that's like
steve is really happy giving sam the
shield
maybe maybe um it's kind of a flashback
to right after end game
and it's like a conversation that we
didn't see before i think that would
actually be
cool i think that might clear up some
things um
maybe maybe like why
exactly sam got the shield right because
a lot of race is involved in this
um and i'm wondering
if it was because he was a black man
that he gave him the shield i'm not sure
right because sam or i'm sorry bucky
apologizes he's
you know he says me and steve you know
we didn't really think
of what it would mean for a black man to
have that shield so maybe he had
something to do with that
um i want to know what steve was
thinking i want to know why he chose sam
over bucky besides the fact that you
know they do it in the comics so um
will old man cap that's how that's how
this question
started will old man cap show up
i don't know because i want to say like
because want a vision
i'll admit i got crazy with the the
mephisto theories i
i'm not ashamed to admit that um
i'm not ashamed to admit that because i
i truly thought it was gonna happen i
think
we found a lot of things that weren't
actually
things for mephisto but um
i i'm not afraid to admit that i got a
little carried away with the uh
with the mephisto with miss pisses up
but so i you know i don't
regarding captain old man steve rogers
you know one division kept it about one
division they they had
you know the two bad guys and i guess
spoiler alert for the finale upon
division if you haven't seen it but
i'm assuming if you're on this live
stream you you have seen it so
so i am about to spoil the ending kind
of for one division so click away
now so at the end
you know we had like the two villains we
had white vision and then we had agatha
but it was still about one division and
even the
the enemy valen vision was still a
vision right so they did a really good
job
at keeping it about the two of them and
this one's called the falcon and the
winter soldier however
steve rogers was a really big part of
bucky and sam's
life like he was their best friend and
bucky has known him since
you know uh a century i mean
essentially right i mean it's uh
it's it's a it's a super strong
relationship
between him and steve and then sam and
steve it's a super big relationship
so uh see steve rogers showing up
that's not something that like doesn't
fit in the story it does fit in the
story
so him showing up would make perfect
sense it would make sense
as far as story plot it would make sense
for the characters um but i'm not
but i'm not saying it's gonna happen i'm
saying that
i want it to happen i do i would like to
see steve
uh i would like to see steve at the end
i i really would
i really would hey legendary one what up
mr anderson's here we got two mods in
the chat we got forsaken
hunter and mr anderson the goat
what have we got yep loki's next i hi
from bangladesh what's up sam sod how's
it going
bangladesh loki's next and
i go i can't tell you how excited i am
for the loki series
i love tom hiddleston and i love loki
like his character
is like one of the best characters like
i really really really really really
really love loki so that's a pretty cool
one and that's next what do we got
like six seven weeks i'm trying to do
the math in my head
but uh i think
i think like i think like six seven
weeks we got into looking so
that is what i
it's hard to say what i'm looking
forward to the most
i think
i i think out of all the series out of
all the tv shows
um i think loki is first and i think
falcon and winter soldier was second
uh i really liked the falcon in the
winter soldier i like it more than i
like to want a vision but i
but i i put them
on a different like i don't know i judge
them differently
or like i liked them differently i think
one division was really really
good as far as like breaking the mold of
what a marvel
project was and i think it was done in a
very very good way
however the falcon number soldier
i said this in some of my reviews feels
like marvel
and i'm loving it because i mean
obviously we're all huge marvel fans
so but it's hard to compare because
they're so different
you know and um
it got very good at the end the finale
the finale was incredible and
i'm gonna assume that tonight's finale
is incredible um
it's all been leading up you know to
this huge
fight and there is a lot of mystery like
involved still because i'm kind of
wondering
like what's the flag smashers plan
like what is it so they're going to
attack the grc
and they're going to get them to try and
stop the vote but like what happens
then right like are the flag smashers
trying to take over the world
i mean even though you have a super
soldier serum like if you face enough
guns
you're gonna get taken down like we saw
carly get shot she was clearly hurt
that was one shot right so i mean what
happens if you just get shot a lot you
get shot in the head
or you get shot in the head a couple of
times like like flex or flex masters
well yeah the flag smasher
and super soldiers they're not
invincible
they're almost indestructible but
they're not invincible i mean just look
at john walker he has a super soldier
ceremony in
last episode they broke his arm so
they're killable
well i mean and i guess john walker
killed nico
so 100 killable so i'm just kind of
wondering like
what's the strat and how are they
working
with how are they working with
um emily vaughn hack
sharon carter that's so uh i will say
that that's
that's been a pretty good part of the
show for me
guessing who sharon carter
i guess who she is i know she is but
like guessing if she is the power broker
and what her motives are like we got
bartrok back bartrock the leaper
he's trying to kill sam sharon put him
in that position uh
and i i'm like maybe it's a plan to get
a bunch of people in the same area
or you know i don't think she's a
villain i don't think she's a villain at
all
um but um i don't know how many people
here
saw me interview the director uh kari
skoglyn
she when i asked her about
when i asked her about sharon carter she
was very
um she didn't want to tell me much about
her
i will say like she said something at
first and she kind of gave me a little
bit and then i had to press a little bit
more and i think i asked like
is this going to be like a defining role
character moment for her
and she she was oh did my other computer
just want to sleep
and she was like we're going to see is
what she said she said we're going to
see about sharon carter
and like that was loud
and now having watched
almost the entire series i get why she
wasn't trying to tell me a lot
because we don't really know and then of
course there's the hilarious
i don't know you call it apple theory or
something like that um but the but the
theory that she is the power broker
because of the iphone that she has um
or no i'm sorry because the android
phone that she has because apple
has a thing like a rule or something
like that like apple law
where their their
their phones cannot be used by villains
and tv shows or movies or whatever
like you can't do that it's like a
strict rule
that apple has so sharon has an android
phone
and other people have other people have
um
apples uh thunderbolt ross as red hulk
in the credits
mk gaming by moonish thank you for that
super chat um
i don't think it's red hulk but what i'm
hoping is
the post credit scene is thunderbolt
ross
visiting the raft which is where uh the
dora malagic took
zemo at the end of well not at the end
but closely in the last episode
so thunderbolt ross is in charge of that
whole thing you know we saw it in civil
war so i'm hoping
thunderbolt ross shows up at the end and
zemo and he kind of tells something to
zemo kind of like
oh you know you got a taste of freedom
like you were out of jail for like a
little bit blah blah blah and he's like
how would you like to really be free
how'd you like to earn your freedom
and that's like the thunderbolts
initiative and stuff like that
oh shield giveaway yeah shield giveaway
um
ends this month what do we have 22nd
maybe i should have planned it for the
finale giving away the shield
that was that would have probably been
more smart
uh let me do a text to talk about the
shield
i'm alive so me
and my buddy and roommate and also
um he's he's the editor for editor for
my cosmic wonder videos
uh chris have the channel cosmic culture
and um uh he's been doing a lot of stuff
lately but i started it and i'm
gonna jump a lot more on it and we're
gonna have a lot more open discussions
um kind of about everything that's
happening
a lot of discussions about everything is
going to happen so it's gonna be fun
it's gonna be pretty open uh it's gonna
be like this except we're going to have
you know like topics at hand that we're
going to talk about
um and maybe we will you know ask the
ask the audience some questions and
maybe some audio is going to come on
stuff like that
it's going to be really fun so if you
haven't subscribed
if you haven't subscribed to cosmic
culture
head over there right now and be sure to
do that we got some cool videos coming
up
speaking of that little mess up right
there i mess up so much when i do my
videos guys like
it's actually pretty funny how much i
mess up
uh i'm gonna start like channel
membership soon
um because like the main videos i put
out
i hear like a lot of news every day
right
and i talk to a lot of people and
some some of its rumors and some of its
real news that i just don't post about
because
i'm i call them bigger videos like
the focus and the the more important
topics are like usually what i try to do
but but i but i ha i hear a lot
and see a lot uh okay gaming by moonish
another super chat yeah i think it would
be really cool i think that
i think that uh would be pretty cool
really cool so um
i i hope it happens because like
i'm kind of curious as to what
what they would put like it could be
a sharon carter thing it could be a zemo
thing
uh kevin stevenson thanks for that super
chat speculation on any credit scene
that's actually what i'm talking about
right now
um my guess would be and i've said this
a few times tonight already
um i know new people are joining
his thunderbolt ross goes to the raft
where the door malaji took zemo
and he's in charge of the raft and it's
a prison full of other bad guys i
believe taskmaster will be there
and he goes and he talks to zemo and is
basically like hey you are free how
would you like to earn your freedom like
how would you like to really be free you
got to do some tasks for me you gotta
maybe you know lead this scene maybe
john walker is there ends up there by
the end of the scene
or into the show so
i don't know no no i don't know um
i'm trying to think of what else it
could really be like
what else could it be like maybe uh
torres could be taurus because remember
he has sam's wings
so i don't think he's
i don't think he's going to show up much
in the end here
so maybe they do a post credit scene for
that like him fixing the wings
like him like you know like he has the
wings with him he looks at him he's like
all right yeah something like that
um i'm not sure something that's
interesting
is there was a
there was a uh tv spot that's the name
of it though
there's a tv spot today that showed
falcon flying with this new suit
didn't have the shield ray charles
thanks for that super chat i appreciate
it
but he didn't have the shield and i'm
wondering you know bucky could be using
it at the time
it could be on the ground i i don't know
but i'm wondering if he decides
not to use it because
like yes the shield is associated with
captain america
oh yeah big time but the shield isn't
captain america like
you don't have to have the shield
to be captain america maybe maybe sam
sort of embraces that right
maybe maybe sam is going to be like oh
uh yeah i don't need to shoot because
you know all the
the struggles we'll call it that he's
had with the shield
right it means different things to
different people it you know maybe the
shield means more to bucky as a symbol
than it does to sam right sam
might think that the shield actually
does belong in a museum
and maybe he says you know you got to
keep it there
i'll be captain america but you got to
keep the shield there because the the
shield was steeps
right the shield yes it's associated
with captain america in the comics all
the stuff
etc etc we associate it with but we've
only had
well wow that's uh really weird i was
going to say
we only have one captain america but we
actually have seen two
uh joaquin fernandez
i have a feeling marvel will combine
both the thunderbolts documentaries into
one team for themselves simplicity
not a bad thought i'm thankful for that
super chat that's not a bad thought um
very possible because of all the stuff
they have going on hello
oh thank you oh wait can you
did you get my text about the shield can
you bring it
i'm gonna show people because the
giveaway is almost here
uh but what can fernando's that is uh
i really like that thought um i
personally would like to have two
different teams
i would like to thunderbolts and the
dark avengers because i think the
thunderbolts um
are almost a team of misfits right um
and the dark vendors are like actual
people hey look
that's what we're giving away
[Music]
my will smith
this is oh my water
no this is a shield we're giving away
i i told him like if we were smart we
would have given it away
today at the finale of them
don't do that math don't do that math
don't question us on that don't question
us on that
just uh just enjoy enjoy just enjoy the
chance of winning shield
because uh we're giving it away in
eight days nine days depending on if
this month goes to the 31st or
uh how can you win the shield i'll show
you right now
yeah yeah he'll show you
you go to the youtubes that's me
uh here we go up there there okay
you go to the youtubes and you
hey wait a minute hey white metal hey
wait a minute
thank you streaming video games hey does
thanks for super chat
uh t nasty nelson we are all captain
america
that's what the statue is captain
america i like the theory
i like it your hair is very long chris
so
bad all right how much for me to cut
chris's hair
all right we'll start the bidding at a
thousand million
one dollar do i have one dollar for me
to cut
for me to cut chris's hair when he's
sleeping i will go into his room i'll
have
his wife record everything and i'll and
i'll go into his head i'll go into his
room
and dial uh and dog cut his hair hold on
what was i doing here cosmic culture
that's chris that's me right there
that's chris this is
uh our channel chris does most of it
but you gotta go to cosmic culture
and subscribe he talks about a lot of
awesome things and uh subscribe to him
and of course subscribe to me
and uh we're gonna choose a winner
april oh look it's 23 so that means
seven days saturday seven days oh wait i
got super shots i'm sorry i didn't mean
to miss any hold on
two or five dollars jake what's up chris
hey that
that's a jig that's a jake uh i'm gonna
miss
any we got white metal
uh
[Music]
pass unwritten thank you for that super
chat why is no one
er and the show acknowledged the shield
just completely different shield
that steve used for most of this history
of his history yeah that was one of big
that was one of the big questions we
actually had after uh avengers end game
we were like that's not the same shield
yeah it was it was different
when he went in the almost said
teleporter time
machine it was different he went in
came back and look at this shield's
completely different right um
you're still still throwing the shield
max conrad what's up chris
hey you know max
um forsaken how much to cut ally's hair
oh
she will be asleep she will be asleep
she does some work for us
and then she she kind of passes out like
in the middle of doing the work
just you know all of the images on their
youtube channels i screenshot them
i almost want to open it here you know
what i could do
oh my gosh guys i'm gonna do it guys
i'm gonna open i can wait that
stormbreaker
first all right i'm gonna do it
guys i'm gonna open stormbreaker right
now there aren't that many of these out
there
there really aren't that many
stormbreakers okay
gonna open stormbreaker on stream why
isn't this working
cut it oh god he's i got five dollars to
cut
do chris's have scissors seriously when
i met chris
his hair was short it was shorter than
my hair because even i have like
never cut it yeah
my thing where's my where's my okay all
right
stormbreaker
also what am i doing i need to turn my
symbol on oh there's a hat in the way
that's a marvel hat
there we go here turn this on for me the
a you gotta get like really close to it
oh no i have super chats
storm breaker has to wait ray charles
thank you for another super chat
all right um hey mate
just curious how many minutes until
episode drops everyone wants to know
well infinity stage thank you for that
super chat
i would say about 45 they tend to
release it like 10 minutes early
did i miss one
ave ave liz i'm so sorry if i can't
pronounce that right
did i miss anymore sean hames
got it gonna cut it all right guys i
gotta film me cutting his we cut his
hair
when he's sleeping at night we've got
enough for it
um
ray charles thanks for another super
chat
hey jake we appreciate that yeah we're
going to do a lot more of that we're
actually starting a show on cosmic
culture
so again be sure to subscribe oh wait
hold on
uh teen nasty nelson that's serious
everyone is capped that's how you tackle
racial diversity issue
of the show 85 sure that's how it's
going to be
well you know you're right about the
whole captain america statue of liberty
thing
and that's actually pretty good what is
that oh no
hello just allison i acknowledge you um
i like that uh t nasty i think that's
really
good and maybe that is because again i
didn't see sam with the shield
all right yes you know it's mine right
you can have no you take the little one
all right
we're going to start here
all right it's open
all right
oh yeah oh there she is some assembly
required
a little listen well i figured it wasn't
all gonna fit in the box
this is what we got so far big old
hammer
we gotta put this thing together
i lost a knife
holy crap i might need scissors
yeah i just don't cut
it don't cut it there's more it's it's
like super
it's like the biggest zip tie ever might
have we might have to get
chris does have thor hair doesn't he
cut your finger not the hammer
it's so close hey
i literally just pulled it out oh from
the other side from those yeah yeah
all right you want to try it again or
you want to go get scissors
do i want to peek too much
all right
look at that look at that
it's bigger than my head which i guess
it should be
oh i get the big one why not it's it's
nice that's pretty good detailing
your screws in there got em